as more and more people around the world
go into self isolation and Quarantine
due to the ongoing coronavirus outbreak
there has been an understandable certain
interest in pandemic movies there have
been a few good ones over the years like
the 90s disaster flick outbreak honey
intelligent take on the zombie genre 28
days later but few seem to be capturing
the public's attention right now quite
as much as Steven Soderbergh's 2011
horrifying ensemble thriller contagion I
think I'm sick what what's going on what
kind of symptoms do you have I can't
swallow believe it or not the movie is
number 2 on iTunes rental charts as of
the making of this video
only bested by Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker not bad for a movie that came
out almost a decade ago for many the
drawer to contagion is their viral
outbreak movie Ducie likely has to do a
lot with how realistic the film set out
to be instead of delivering outlandish
Hollywood thrills screenwriter Scott Z
burns wanted to create a realistic film
that drew from the experiences of actual
people who dealt with pandemics burns
interviewed epidemiologists biologists
and other experts in an attempt to
create a fictional plague that would
feel true to life we can safely say that
he did a terrifyingly good job given how
close to reality contagion often feels
there's a lot of interest and how this
fictional worldwide outbreak comes to an
end so let's take a look at how Soda
Berg's film concludes contagion begins
on day 2 of a global pandemic of caused
by a fictional viral infection
eventually dubbed mev 1 the events of
the film kick off in Minneapolis based
business executive Beth travels to Hong
Kong and Macau for work and becomes
infected with the novel virus before
traveling back to the US after Beth dies
of the illness and a son passes a few
days later there are already dozens of
other mev won cases around the world
by the time scientists realize what's
going on it has already spread out of
control the ensemble film primarily
focuses on the doctors and scientists
working to understand and contain the
viral outbreak dr. Alice Cheever and
Ally Hextall of the Centers for Disease
Control attempt to reduce the spread of
mev one within the US and were to
develop a vaccine while dr. leigh Anora
Arantes of the World Health Organization
travels
Hong Kong in an attempt to track down
the origins of the virus and learn how
it was able to spread out from Southeast
Asia and in fact the rest of the world
after tracking best movements during a
trip to Asia doctor or auntie's is able
to determine on day 14 of the pandemic
but Beth was not only patient zero of
the outbreak in the US but also of the
virus itself however at the CDC the
novel nature of the virus has made it
difficult to study by day 21
dr. heck still sees evidence that the
virus is mutating and becoming even more
deadly wired safer medication looted
grocery stores and MD trash filled
streets have become the norm and dr.
Hextall races against the clock to
unlock the code to a vaccine that will
effectively stop the virus without first
killing the host if we even had a viable
vaccine right now we would still have to
do human trials and that would take
weeks finally on day 29 she cracks it
and develops are working vaccine in
order to fast-track availability of a
new vaccine
dr. Hextall conducts the first human
tests on herself
injecting it into her own leg before
going to visit her father who is
infected with mev one in the hospital to
test its effectiveness with a vaccine
develops the mev one outbreak begins to
wane on day 135
dr. Cheever declares dr. Hextall a hero
but she rejects a label and a spotlight
that it would bring instead we see dr.
Hextall triumphantly placing a sample of
a vaccine in cold storage along with the
vaccines for SARS and h1n1 in the final
scene of contagion we get a flashback
that solves a mystery of how the virus
originated earlier in the film
dr. heck stole most of the MeV one virus
contains strains of both bats and pig
DNA and in the flashback we see a colony
of bats disturbed from a tree that's
being bulldozed by a truck from the very
company that Beth worked for later one
of the bats drops a piece of banana
which came in contact with the virus in
a nearby pig farm a pig eats a piece of
banana and is later sold and butchered
relate to see the pig being prepared in
the kitchen of a fancy casino in Macau
after handling the infected animal the
chef has summoned away from his work he
heads south of the kitchen without
washing up and poses for a photo with
Beth this we learn was day one check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail said you know me
a single one